O'Malley versus you I don't [ __ ] know  dude these guys aren't even [ __ ]  man-sized what are these guys you're  like I [ __ ] chicks at way more than  these guys  [Music]  I'm gonna go with the upset and Sean  O'Malley taking it Taking it home just  because I see him coming out a little  stronger winning that first round and uh  keeping the range keeping the distance  and getting a decision when well I think  people are given they're really  underestimating Sean O'Malley you know  the fact that a great head movement and  very hard guy hits hard you know what I  mean and whenever you're able to  generate that kind of power you're  always dangerous  um but I think that people just realize  that Peter Yawn is put in the work and  he is just the Beast that he is you know  what I mean I think he's a different  Enigma the range of Sean O'Malley the  speed of Sean O'Malley the power of Sean  O'Malley if this fight stays on the feet  I think purion's in for a tough night